may 16th 1919 an historic day in aviation
start of the first flight ever to be made
across the Atlantic three American flying
boats made the attempt from Newfoundland
this is the MC three later to be forced
down with a sister ship the NC one but
one of the flying pioneers did make it made
it in 11 days after the takeoff and here it
is the trailblazing MC 4 you are watching
the actual start of the flight that made
history actually only 42 hours were spent in
the air but it was not until May 27 that the
flying ship was set down at its destination
Lisbon Portugal had to stop off at the Azores
the nz4 and its crew members photographed
after the flight and here is its skipper
on the 1919 trip commander read now it's
Admiral read thirty years later joining
with Commander Tom Davis to duplicate
the mc4 is epic adventure also on the
journey with the NC forest machinists mate
eugene roads 1949 s truculent turtle which
will take read davis and roads along
the same course charted by the MC for
sixteen hours and 50 minutes from this point
the tittle will accomplishment took the MC
for forty two flying hours and eleven days
to do the truculent turtle the Navy's most
famous long-distance guyliner yesterday's news
we represent the old and the new in aviation